>>> WHOA, I HOPE YOU ARE HAVING
FUN.
I KNOW IT SUCKS BRAD'S OUT OF
TOWN.
>> YEAH, BUT IT'S NICE TO HAVE
SOME ME TIME, RIGHT?
>> THERE SHE IS.
>> STEVE, STOP.
>> WHAT?
I CAN'T HELP IT.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
>> OH.
WATCH IT GUY.
>> OH YOU WANT TO FIGHT ME?
LET'S GET IT, BRO.
>> OKAY THAT'S MY CUE, I GOT TO
GET HIM OUT OF HERE.
>> OKAY, SEE YOU GUYS LATER.
>> YOU WILL NEVER FIND LOVE LIKE
THIS.
>> OKAY --
>> WISHING YOUR MAN WAS HERE?
HE WOULD BE A HANDFUL BUT WOW DO
YOU MISS HIM.
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
INTRODUCING MY DRUNK BOYFRIEND.
THE ONLY LIFE SIZED DOLL
GUARANTEED TO MAKE YOU FEEL LIKE
YOUR MAN IS RIGHT THERE WITH
YOU.
AND HE'S HAMMERED, 150 POUNDS OF
DEAD WEIGHT, AND YOU GET TO BE
HIS BABY-SITTER.
DESIGNED TO MIMIC THE BEHAVIOR
OF THE SLOPPY GROWN MAN THAT YOU
CAN'T GET ENOUGH OF.
PROGRAMMED TO SAY OVER
200 UNIQUE PHRASES.
>> I THINK I'M GOING TO TAKE
PIANO LESSONS.
>> IT'S ALWAYS A FUN NIGHT WITH
MY DRUNK BOYFRIEND.
>> COPS, WHO WANTS COPS.
>> YOU'LL LIKE HEARING ABOUT HIS
BIG PLANS.
>> I'M GOING TO DO IT.
I'M GOING THE CALL MY BOSS AND
QUIT.
>> OR WHEN HE CRIES OVER A DEAD
RELATIVE WHICH HE'S NEVER
MENTIONED BEFORE.
>> MY UNCLE.
MY UNCLE.
>> WITH MY DRUNK BOYFRIEND
BESIDE YOU, YOU WILL NEVER MISS
OUT ON A NIGHT OF ROLLING HIM
OVER WHEN HE SNORES.
AND OH, NO.
WATCH OUT.
MY DRUNK BOYFRIEND HAS A TIMER
SET TO GET UP IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT AND PEE INTO YOUR
HAMPER.
>> THAT'S THE LAUNDRY.
>> DID GOOD RIGHT?
>> PLUS WITH THE NEW MY DRUNK
BOYFRIEND EXPANSION PACK YOU
WILL GET ALL SORTS OF
ACCESSORIES, LIKE PANTS THAT
DON'T COME ALL THE WAY OFF.
A CHARRED FROZEN PIZZA THAT HE
BROUGHT INTO BED.
A GLASS OF WATER HE WILL IGNORE,
AND JUST ONE MORE BEER.
MY DRUNK BOYFRIEND.
HE'S A PROBLEM, BUT HE'S YOUR
PROBLEM.
>> FROM THE MAKERS OF MY DRUNK
GIRLFRIEND.
>> ARE YOU MAD AT ME?
>> YEAH, I'M MAD AT YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪